a brand-new month is approaching and
that means it's the perfect time to let
go you can play the 30 day minimalism
game and also download our free
printable 30-day minimalism game
calendar over at the minimalists comm
slash game enjoy has bad words hello
everybody welcome to the minimalist
podcast where we discuss what it means
to live a meaningful life with less my
name is Joshua Fields Milburn and I'm
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists Wow today we're here with
our returning champion Ben Greenfield
and I'm the champion yeah man I love now
how do you feel about this because you
are the the final guest of this decade
this decade you know basically means
like you put off interviewing me for an
entire decade and at the very last
minute slip to the end no way this is
your the returning champion yeah you've
been here before we're gonna talk today
is perfect we thought would have been on
because he's back in town and we're
gonna talk about resolutions because I
don't know anyone who puts himself he's
the human guinea pig he puts himself
through more experiments makes more sort
of resolutions than anyone else you may
not use that terminology
I prefer immersive journalist a human
guinea pig I just think it's too close
to a lab rat tail well today we're gonna
talk about in the year's resolutions
we're gonna talk about when it's
appropriate to give up on a resolution
we're gonna talk about what actions you
need to take when you're feeling stuck
and so let's dive into our questions
today oh by the way Ben his podcast you
can check it out it's called the Ben
Greenfield fitness podcast I encourage
you to listen to it I listen to it and
you should as well our first question
today is from Andy in Georgia hi this is
Andy from Marietta Georgia and I have
been working on minimalist life for a
couple of months now and I've explored
all aspects from stuff to time to
finances and I'm really struggling with
this idea of sleep specifically going to
bed earlier I started getting up earlier
but I have two little ones so the
morning and evening or my best time and
I've never been a morning person but my
brain is definite
it was foggy in the a.m. so any advice
you have for going to bed earlier would
be greatly appreciated then when do you
go to bed usually between about 9:30 and
10:00 p.m. with the idea being that
suppose you do want to fall into that 7
to 9 hour time frame at which we know
most adults lie in terms of their sleep
needs you need to be in bed for a
certain period of time right so if you
if I'm in bed for 8 hours I get about 7
and a half hours of sleep right and if
I'm in bed you know eight and a half
hours I can get a full full eight hours
so I'm pretty protective of my sleep I I
go to bed at a pretty decent time and
you know when I'm camping when I'm
hunting like I'm in bed by 8:00 8:30
right like it's far far easier in
sundown in the absence of artificial
light and blue light to go to bed and
tap into the true primal natural
ancestral circadian rhythms to which
we're all tuned and in a case like that
I'm waking out to do right well what
what she needs to do is in in sleep
medicine there is a term basically known
as a circadian rhythm shift right she
needs to shift her circadian rhythmicity
to cause her to begin getting tired
earlier begins sending a message to her
body that her sleep time is maybe an
hour earlier or two hours earlier than
what it normally is and the key to
shifting the circadian rhythm and this
is great for anybody who's traveling
east coast west coast west coast East
Coast who is jet-lagged who needs to
phase shift based on where they happen
to be on the globe the key to this
begins with light in the morning that is
when your sleep cycle cycle begins is
the amount of light you're exposed to
and at what time you are exposed to that
light now what kind of sunlight is
obviously optimal but what if you live
somewhere by Ryan and I lived in Montana
well you live in Spokane and so in the
winter in Spokane sometimes what 9:30
10:00 o'clock before it gets light out
yeah absolutely so first of all let's
say that
you're waking at 5:00 a.m. and you want
to shift everything forward and begin
waking later and going to sleep slightly
later when you wake at 5:00 a.m. you
would limit your exposure to blue light
artificial light screens backlit LEDs
monitors television even going outside
in the sunshine you would wear those
blue light blockers that they give
people to wear at night in the morning
instead and when you want your body to
begin waking up let's say that's 6:30
a.m. that's when you begin blasting it
with light that's when you go out in the
sunlight that's when you take your phone
out of dark mode that's when you begin
looking at computer monitors that's when
you may even consider utilizing any of
these new technologies that blast your
retina or your ears with blue light or
white light such as like a human charger
in the ears not so much the Juve light
that's more kind of like a sunset maybe
you get a little bit of the the spectrum
from sunlight but that's more like a red
light near-infrared that's really not
going to face shift the circadian rhythm
there is a pair of glasses called the
retime errs that you can wear that
blasts your retina with this greenish
blue light but ultimately you wait and
wait and wait until the time you want to
begin waking up and you phase shift your
circadian rhythm forward now the same
thing could be done if you want to as
what was her name as Andy wants to do
shift it backwards right in this case
let's say she wants to begin going to
bed at 9:30 p.m. she's currently
beginning her day at 6:30 a.m. and wants
to start her day at 5:00 or 5:30 a.m.
she would begin to wake at an earlier
time and as soon as she wakes get out
into the sunlight or blast the eyes with
one of these light producing devices
like the retime ER or a seasonal
affective disorder blue light box or put
in those human charger in-ear blue light
buds look at her phone and make sure the
phone is not in dark mode ensure she's
not wearing any blue light blocking
glasses etc and that will shift her
entire circadian rhythm backwards so
she's more alert and awake earlier in
the day and then as the day progresses
she's basically getting that sleep
pressure at an earlier time in the day
because she started the light at an
earlier time in the day so it's it's
very profound how quickly the body
circadian rhythm responds to light with
the only other cues be
movement any type of food intake right
so that would mean like she's shifting a
breakfast slightly earlier she's
shifting her exercise session slightly
earlier and if you look at light
movement and food those are the top
three they called them something like
site-geist or zeitgeist on meaning that
those are things that affect your
circadian rhythm by shifting it forwards
or backwards this is something that I
thought was appropriate for the the
resolutions episode because so many
people struggle with sleep and they make
it a sort of goal but they we often
don't make it a priority and I think
that's the main thing here there are a
lot of you sort of sleep acts that
you're talking about here and these
things are all useful and and beneficial
but I think quite often what happens is
well we get home and then yeah all of a
sudden we make dinner and put the kids
to bed and now I want to veg out and
we're gonna turn the TV on and before
you know it it's 10:30 11:30 midnight
and I think quite often this has to do
with prioritizing sleep over some of
these more ephemeral pacifiers yeah
absolutely I live my life largely by the
philosophy of crushing the day and using
the night as my reboot button because
what I found is that not a lot of
productivity happens in the evening I
get fewer work-related emails or text
messages or push notifications there is
you know there are fewer productive
networking events or meetups usually the
nighttime activities are involved around
like drinking and joking or being
entertained so I make the decision to do
most of my networking most of my media
consumption my emails
boxers text messages anything like that
during the day and once about 9 p.m. or
so rolls around I find that not a lot of
productivity occurs after 9:00 and if
you're living life by the mindset of
being a creator rather than a consumer
then you are best served by crushing the
day and then basically halting your
nighttime activities at about the point
where productivity ceases and for me
that's around 9 p.m. or so ya know one
one thing I didn't hear you
mention with your recommendation Andy is
any supplements are there any
supplements that like I know melatonin
is something that you know use as
necessary but don't use often cos and
you start to rely on it there are a
couple of supplements I was recommended
it's like one of those the four sig
Matic like mushroom blends that I'll
drink in the morning that actually I
have noticed a little bit I'm getting to
sleep a little bit easier at night
there's another supplement I can't
remember but is there any supplements
that you would recommend that are okay
to help you fall asleep besides the
obvious like melatonin yeah only two and
I should mention that you know light is
almost a supplement and of itself
oh [ __ ] photons of light interact with
the body and so of course my
recommendations would carry on into the
evening meaning that you would want to
in the same way that you're just
blasting yourself with artificial light
or blue light or sunlight in the morning
get complete absence of that whenever
the Sun Goes Down in the area of the
world you happen to be in so that's when
you you know install iris tech on your
computer monitor or which limits all
blue light from coming up the screen
where your blue light blockers put your
phone and dark mode you know etc as far
as supplements go really the only two
that that I think have good research
behind them for initiating a sleep cycle
in a very effective manner
other than melatonin which you which you
already referred to in which we we make
less of as we age and is important to
supplement with especially as you age
I'll often take up to 60 milligrams of
melatonin when I'm traveling
internationally just to jumpstart my
circadian rhythm into the time zone
where I happened to be in so with
melatonin I've heard different
recommendations as far as when to take
it is there like do you take it with
dinner because I've heard take it with
dinner and then I've heard take it you
know a half hour before you go to bed is
there a specific timing when you would
take to 60 minutes prior to bed okay
yeah yeah and you know some some
companies sell a time-release melatonin
you might be able to take that a little
farther from bed but I use a I use a
really powerful liposomal form of
melatonin I get it from Quicksilver
scientific it's a few sprays under the
tongue it's it's the most potent form of
melatonin I've been able to find but in
addition to that the only other two
would be GABA gamma-aminobutyric
it's an inhibitory neurotransmitter your
body makes it when you have a glass of
wine which is why a lot of people kind
of like to have a glass of wine at the
end of the day to wind down but you can
also purchase it in supplemental form
there are certain natural extracts like
valerian or passionflower you know in T
or in tincture format and that cause
your body to release its own GABA there
are other supplements that for example
there's one called sleep remedy there
are multiple standalone GABA supplements
you can buy on Amazon or Deni you know
any pharmacy and so gaba would be one
and then the other one would be CBD but
with the understanding that most of the
sleep data on CBD is showing results
with dosages of 100 to 300 milligrams
and a standard dosage in a CBD bottle
like a tincture bottle one dropper falls
around 10 milligrams so most brands are
not using much CBD I was looking just
because I'm here in California and
there's you know there's there's weed
shops all over the place and CBD coming
up people's pours I did I was I was
looking I was walking through Venice
Beach and walked into one store and they
had a CBD brand there I think it was
green helix and it was CBD capsules and
I noted it was 50 MiG's per capsule
that's the highest I've seen and I was
actually pleased to see that they were
marketing that as a sleep product
because that's clubbing taking two to
six of those capsules would be closer to
the actual amount that's been shown in
research to assist with sleep so in
addition to melatonin CBD and gaba CBD
and gaba and you would take those 20 to
60 minutes before sleep as well exactly
I further with marijuana that when
you're sleeping you do get some like
really great REM sleep but it affects
the deep sleep but I might be thinking
of like the THC form of it instead of
the CBD do you know any THC will
decrease the amount of deep sleep that
you get right so if you're taking an
edible like an indica or sativa you know
normally it'd be an indica for for like
a nighttime cookie or edible or vape N
or anything like that you will sleep and
it won't be bad sleep you just won't get
as much deep restorative sleep however
you know during a lot of that rent
sleep you know you are still engaged in
memory consolidation and learning and
dreaming and you know assimilating
information and activities and
encounters that you had during the day
so one could say there's some benefit to
more REM sleep however there's a lot of
nervous system repair that occurs during
those deep sleep cycles that I think a
lot of when I look at people sleep
cycles from from from a loop wristband
or an aura ring or an Apple watch or
anything else it's usually the deep
sleep that tends to be the lowest and so
I question whether people should be
using a sleep supplement that further
decreases deep sleep percentages versus
just using CBD and isolation which
actually increases deep sleep
percentages that's good to know CBD
increases the deep sleep okay some
contradicting studies so maybe even
clearer clarify this with CBD I've seen
that it helps with deep sleep as long as
you take it earlier in the day but he's
take it later in the day it may actually
decrease deep sleep you have you have
you seen any literature on that I've not
seen any literature on that the only the
only diurnal variation in CBD response
that I've seen is that in lower doses
during the daytime it can increase
alertness or like a 10 to 20 milligram
dose but when taking at 100 to 300
milligrams and the evening can increase
deep sleep percentages I haven't seen
what you've just alluded to but there
there might be research that exists that
I'm gonna wear of well let's let's send
Andy a copy of dr. Matthew Walker's book
why we sleep now speaking of books been
you ever finally you've spent several
years on this new book it's called
boundless and I would encourage folks
they can pre-order it right now in fact
Sean can we put a link to his new book
in the show notes can we talk a little
bit about about this new book there's
been a a labor of love and hate is the
same time love and hate it's you know
every author and the health space says
one of the unhealthiest things that you
can do is to write a book because you're
you know ass planted in a chair your
eyes getting burnt out by a computer
monitor for hours on end
writing and I like to write you know
this is not something that I that I went
through a ghost author for you know one
of those record your book type of
services you write some fiction as well
I write fiction as well yeah I was
actually writing fiction in the uber on
the way over here and so
anyways though it's has been about three
years in the making and the concept
behind it is that unlike previous books
I've written with which are largely
focused on unfitness on training etc
this book is is a beast it was 1,200
pages the manuscript when I turned it in
to the publisher women the most 3,000
scientific reference is definitely not
minimalistic we managed to get it down
to about six hundred and eight pages
which is the final book big beautiful
hardcover coffee table esque book
diagrams illustrations focal I wanted it
to be like a piece of art right so it's
it'll be in Kindle and an audiobook as
well but the hardcover is is the piece
of art almost like the 4-hour body on
steroids the idea is that it split into
three sections mind body and spirit so
the mind or the brain section covers
everything from mold and mycotoxins and
lime and diets to support cognition
nootropics to smart drug to bio hacking
technologies for the brain etc the body
section is all fitness fat loss immune
system jet lag you know battling colds
and flus getting recovered faster just
everything that has arisen since I wrote
my initial book beyond training as far
as everything from from bio hacking to
supplements to diets to exercise
strategies for the body and then and
this is probably the most unique part of
the book I wove in a lot of it was over
200 pages of anti-aging and longevity
advice and there from you know peptides
and Psalms and hormones to a bunch of
things that the Blue Zones are doing
spirituality is covered when it comes to
gratitude sexual performance
relationships battling loneliness
purpose meditation fasting gratitude you
know all of these different spiritual
disciplines that I think are often left
out of a health book and so I call it
boundless because the entire premise of
the book is that by going through it you
discover how to have boundless energy
your beck-and-call day in and day out
and yeah it's
it's a giant book but I like to write
big books I don't like flash-in-the-pan
you know like little 200-page Airport
bookshelf books they can get through in
two days like I want a book that that
lasts me for like a good year just going
through everything in it and wouldn't
feel I can return to again and again so
I check it out and I tell you what shot
if we gets an Andy a copy of boundless
as well
that'd be great our next question is
from Kelly in Chicago the question I was
going to ask you you're gonna complete
address minimalism in volunteering and
time commitment in your life because I
tend to commit myself to a lot of
different things mostly with my kids
school PPO all that stuff how do you
commit to helping groups that are
worthwhile to help yet still keep enough
time for yourself so that you're saying
so I think one thing that's fascinating
we're thinking about the new year and we
don't obviously wait for the new year to
make any sort of resolution but one
thing we often do is we over commit and
that actually prevents us from
committing to things that are most
meaningful to us so can we tell you're
someone who's able to to sort of juggle
a bunch of chainsaws at once can we talk
a little bit about about not over
committing then I think there there are
two things to bear in mind here the
first is that you must put on your own
accent oxygen mask first meaning that if
you don't have some kind of self-care or
self-love process whether that's
exercise or taking time to meditate or
engage in breath work or gratitude
practice or anything else before you run
off to go help other people you are that
much less equipped to be able to make a
lasting impact on the world so
everything I do for anti-aging for
longevity it's not so I can brag about
being the person who lives the longest
it's so that during my time here on the
earth I'm able to be as best equipped
from a physical standpoint to be able to
make as big an impact as I can on the
planet with my life's purpose which
leads to point number two you need to
have a filter you need to have a purpose
right like my purpose in life is to
empower people to live a more
adventurous joyful and fulfilling life
that is my purpose and when I'm looking
at volunteer opportunities when I'm
looking at speaking opportunity
when I'm looking at article writing
opportunities or podcasts or anything
else I can put things through that
filter I can say okay you know by by me
going and volunteering at the Spokane
Union Gospel Mission and let's say
helping to hand out clothing to two
homeless men is that empowering people
to live a more adventurous joyful and
fulfilling life versus say playing my
guitar at a nursing home you know and
playing some cool hymns and old country
songs for the people at the nursing home
well for me personally the ladder Falls
a little bit more into like the joy and
adventure component and that kind of
lights me up a little bit so I'll choose
something like that we get caught up
because we say well this is a good
option this is a good option and and
that's a good problem to have but but
then picking the one that better aligns
with who you are who you want to be how
you want to serve the world I think sets
you up to be happier more fulfilled and
well to be a better version of yourself
everyone has a unique skill set and
don't feel bad if what turns you on as
far as helping people is different than
what turned someone else on and if you
are turning down ways that you can help
people to be of a better service in a
different way that fits your skill set I
think that's just fine yeah what I'm
hearing you guys say is like you're
helping Kelly figure out what she needs
to say no to so she can actually say yes
to the things that matter most her but
I'll tell you like for me when I want to
add something into my routine earn into
my calendar I do exactly that like I go
to my calendar and I'm literally
budgeting my time and Kelly if you're
not budgeting your time correctly you're
not even gonna know where you are
available to give yourself but look at
that schedule and yeah look at yours
look at look at what you have on your
plate and ask yourself like what do I
need to say no to in order so I can say
yes to the important things in life
Kelly I'm gonna send you a copy of our
book essential speaking of priorities so
essential was an essay collection with
150 different essays twelve different
areas of intentional living one of those
areas is figuring out what your
priorities are so if you like our
podcast you'll really like the audio
book version of essential it's like it's
six hours long maybe a little bit over
six hours so Sean if you could
send her that or if you want the book
book or the e-book we're happy to send
those to you as well Kelly Ryan what
time is it you know what time it is it
it's time for our lightning round where
we answer questions from social media
indeed we do we're at the minimalists on
Twitter Facebook and Instagram and then
Ben is at Ben Greenfield on definitely
on Twitter I think Instagram as well I
think so and all the Ben Greenfield
videos alright well we'll put a link to
his website in the show notes as well
and you can find him on all the social
media platforms where we got Ryan we got
a question from Nick I've started and
stopped minimalism so many times how do
I ensure it sticks rather than having to
set it as a resolution 20 more times so
you can replace this word minimalism I
think with just about anything where
I've started blank a new diet a new
exercise routine I've tried to go to bed
earlier whatever it might be but then I
stopped doing it I stopped feeling
motivated or as Nick says it never
sticks now Ben what we tried to do is we
try to give a pithy answer but we can
ramble on a little bit Sean puts all of
our quotes and the show notes and we put
them over at minimal Maxim's calm as
well so here's my pithy answer actually
I have I have three of them for you
because I'm all the ultimate minimalist
first one is sometimes you have to walk
away to come back and what I mean by
that is maybe you tried something but it
wasn't the appropriate time for you to
try it in your life maybe you had other
things going on other things were a
priority then now now priority it's a
weird thing we've made this word
priority a plural it wasn't a plural
into the 20th century priority literally
means the first thing and so what is the
first thing for you that changes over
time my second pit the answer is because
here it's a brand new year I tweaked
this at the first day of every year one
day or day one you decide and I think
quite often with minimalism or diet or
something else its I'll get to that one
day right which race is my third my
third answer here is some day is not a
day of the week and someone will often
say I'll do it some day or I'll do
tomorrow I'll put it off and and we we
continue to pass tonight now Ben do you
have any advice for Nick for getting
something to stick yeah I think but I
think two of the big things that I do
are I equip my environment to enable me
the next day to do what it is I'd plan
to do so let's take exercise for example
when I plan to go to the gym my clothes
are laid out when I wake up I know
exactly what shoes I'm gonna wear those
are there the entire workout is jotted
down on a notepad or on the notes
function on my iPhone so there's very
little barrier to entry there's very
little paralysis by analysis or
decision-making fatigue for me to
actually remove the friction that's a
great way to explain it and then the
other thing I've done in terms of
removing the friction is you eliminate
as many barriers to you engaging in that
activity as possible meaning that if
your goal is to begin eating healthy you
literally throw out or give to someone
you don't like you know all the peanut
butter all the ice cream all the pop
cards just do not have it in the home
period you know I I happen to be staying
in a very stripped-down apartment while
I'm here in Venice Beach because my
friend is moving but I've crashed at his
home where he basically has a bed a
couch and a Wi-Fi router and a little
bulldog named Jack when you open the
refrigerator there's nothing in the
pantry there's a little bit of salt and
black pepper I have had zero cheat
nights since I got here because I have
zero options when I get home they're
there there is no chocolate bar in the
freezer there is no Jarrah peanut butter
in the pantry there is nothing and when
you simply kind of paint yourself into
that corner it makes things far easier
you know when you combine that with a
plan like I was talking about earlier
like here's exactly what I'm going to
eat for breakfast snack lunch and dinner
you're far more equipped because I think
that where people fail a lot of times is
just not knowing what to do or being
surrounded by the activities or the
objects that take them away from what it
is that they had planned on doing then
it's interesting how you're talking
about removing the friction for exercise
but you're adding a little bit of
friction when it comes to diet because
if you've got yeah the junk food sitting
around it's really easy to just kind of
fall into bad habits that way my pithy
answer is this lifestyle changes
are more effective than dieting so with
anything when it comes to well he asked
about minimalism you can't look at it
like oh I'm gonna be a minimalist for it
for 30 days we do have the 30 day
minimalism game it's a great way to get
started but if that's where it ends then
you're gonna fall right back into your
old habits and it's the same thing with
dieting I mean I can't tell you how many
times I was like oh I need to lose 10
pounds so I'm gonna be a vegan for a
year on a bet or I'm going to I'm gonna
go on a juicing you know juicing cleanse
to lose some weight well guess what when
that time frame is over it's not long
before I'm right back in my old habits
to my old weight so yes Nick you got to
look at it as a lifestyle change and
it's not it's not just ya picking it up
as a habit you've got to commit to it
all right before we get into our added
value segment and our listener tips
today it looks like we got a bunch more
surprise questions this week why don't
most resolutions work how do I avoid
becoming overwhelmed by commitments this
year how can I change a negative mindset
that tells me I will never get in shape
what are some simple steps for busy
people to become healthier so many busy
people out there Ryan yeah busy busy
busy
including Ben Ben is very busy so we'll
talk to him about what busy people do to
become healthier I think we got about 6
million more questions for Ben hmm
plus we're gonna talk about our own
personal resolutions we're gonna talk
about setting monthly resolutions and
we're gonna talk about what it would
take to create the best year ever and if
you want to hear all that you can listen
to this week's maximal episode available
exclusively on patreon that's right
you're currently listening to our weekly
minimal episode but each week Ryan and I
record an entirely different much longer
maximal episode over on the minimalists
private podcast which gives us the
private space we need to talk about
petha box we don't usually discuss in
public plus patreon is the best way for
us to fund this podcast and keep it 100%
advertisement free when you subscribe to
the minimalist private podcast on
patreon you will receive a personal link
so that our maximal episodes play and
your favorite podcast app you can find
all the details and all the good stuff
over at the minimalists com slash
support I know it's it's just 2 dollars
but we really appreciate that support
and we are actually capping
the audience over there right so it's a
new year right now I don't know where we
are on subscriber count but we're
probably about a thousand away we're
we're capping the audience at about six
thousand patrons and that's because we
figured out what enough was for us
enough to pay Jordan and Sean and Jess
and ourselves and for this beautiful
studio space and our secret storage
calls it over there that's right Josh
you know you're forgetting to mention
with the with the the patreon support we
get to hear about Ben's penis injections
and I'll just leave it at that we
talking to VIN about his penis
I got some voicemail comments and tips
from our listeners here you go man check
them out hello my name is Meghan and
today is my 18th birthday and I'm
currently a senior in high school I hear
about the college application process
for my peers on a daily basis and I
believe that it has consumed them well
for good reason it is a stressful
process but nevertheless I can never
seem to escape the noise at this point
I've submitted all of my applications to
nine colleges and sometimes I think
about if I'm going to make the right
decision before next May for which one
to commit you I really enjoy listening
to the recent episode called student
debt and found it a much-needed reminder
to heavily consider the future cost of
going to college I knew going into this
process that the cost of tuition would
be a factor that I should consider in
terms of where I should go but the
episode really opened my eyes to the
burden that student debt puts on people
I would HIGHLY encourage any high
schooler planning to go to college or
any person thinking of getting a degree
in the future to listen to any episode
also do your homework
there are many websites like scholarship
Tom in fact Lib comm that give you
access to national scholarships as well
as local scholarship that you can apply
for
hi Josh and Ryan's Jeremy flick and I
want to believe a tip that would be
helpful hopefully to all creators out
there I'm a songwriter myself and I'm
finding that the app Evernote it's
really helpful for multiple uses
but for songwriting in general it has a
built-in voice recorder as you can
categorise notes in a lot of different
ways you can get pictures and it's all
done within the app with cloud storage
as well you can log on a desktop or your
mobile device so I find myself on long
car ride to and from work thinking of
song ideas recording them writing lyrics
one of the restroom or at home whenever
I have time to do so extremely helpful
for me and my craft and I hope others
find it helpful as well with a free
option
there's also monthly storage that you
can add on for a small fee but Evernote
is great app I use it religiously and I
hope you find it helpful
alright y'all thanks again to Ben
Greenfield for joining us today check
out his podcast the Ben Greenfield
fitness podcast wherever find podcasts
are sold
do they sell podcast patent-pending and
check out his new book as well it comes
out in January it's called boundless
we'll put a link to that in the show
notes as well and real quick four right
here right now here is one thing that is
going on in the life of the minimalists
if you go over to the minimalists
dot-com that's our website say that five
times fast and you click on the
resources tab at the top we have eight
new resources for you a bunch of
different things including a 30-day
minimalism game calendar you know
someone's making a minimalist joke right
now right what's at a very minimal
amount of resources why are you charging
such a minimal amount of money it's free
yeah yeah I get it but we have some
resources over we have some free
wallpapers we have the 30 day minimalism
game calendar we have the minimalist
rulebook 16 rules for living with less a
bunch of other things over there the
minimalists Calm resources page a bunch
of free downloads for you if you have a
question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast leave us a voicemail for
zero six two one nine seven eight three
nine or send a voice memo to pod
cast at the minimalists calm you can
comment on this episode at youtube.com
slash the minimalists if you want our
show notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at the minimalists comm
you'll also receive our simple Sunday
emails for our added value this week
Ryan there's a new EP out we were we
were jamming to it the other day do you
remember we were in here practicing for
a speech they were giving and I put on a
song and we were having a little dance
party in the studio yeah dude I felt
young you looked young and they are
young there's a I you know it's fun I
have a rather eclectic taste in music
but that's somewhat intentional I tried
to stay up on like new music I heard
this kind of so hip-hop well this is
know definitely I have five minutes it's
like pop music right and uh it's a a
group or a band a group a singing group
called pretty much to say hit word hop
would be like it is hip and it's pop
that's good but a hip pop is it that
would be like I'm just repeating myself
right no that would be what happens when
you fall down the stairs you have a hip
pop oh okay
what are we listening to pretty much
yeah let's listen to a group call pretty
much it's the title track from their new
EP phases and if you live here today
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all we'll see you next time
minimus